a determinação
eu trabalhava no arquivo morto arquivo
morto uma coisa que hoje em dia acho que
existe mais um ficava selecionando
documento
às vezes era mandar embora 70 80 de uma
vez eu tinha que se separar
reginaldo oliveira gonçalves janeiro de
2002 ronaldo oliveira gonçalves
fevereiro de 2002 era um trabalho muito
bom você imagina trancado na casa
dezenas de arquivos e do lado tinha sede
da empresa
nesse mesmo ano 1996 já caiu é verdade
né
bom nesse mesmo ano 1986
eu fui passagem da empresa e lá tinha um
concurso de poesia na casa de cultura de
santo amaro
eu me inscrevi garotão gostava de poesia
pra caramba e na quebrada
nunca te vi ninguém fazer poesia eu não
sabia que depois quer evitar na rua que
lhe rendeu o porteiro de boston
mas eu comecei a fazer poesia comecei
com a empresa chegava na hora do
cafezinho tava lá o anúncio do café e
arrancava colocavam poesia minha chegada
no banheiro tinha lá haver descargas
arrancava colocavam poesia me logo meu
gerente me chamou e falou lá com essa
coisa de bosta que fica quando a empresa
vai dar merda vai dar merda mas mal
tocou na poesia mas levantamento a
entender pensa o pensamento que tem esse
pensamento que pensa e fazer coisas
concretas marca dialoga com o
construtivismo de são paulo vai dar
merda
a dona da empresa dona ana maria
detalhes vasconcelos pinheiro
ela chegava de uma empresa ela
praticamente não comentar com ninguém
ele olhar os cachorros ela pegava na rua
ela sempre tinha ido pegar os cachorros
e criar todo mundo a empresa tinha muito
medo e ela mandou me chamar na sala
osmar fala falei que dá pra entender
nada além de mal poeta é analfabeto você
vai ver foi tremendo na sala dela
entrei ela fosse você que tá bom nessas
poesia e na empresa como café erva no
barreiro não pode funcionar ao mesmo
dono
adoro poesia legal dá né
que bom se não está montando um livro
alguma coisa um projeto viver como se
trazer a empresa tem como símbolo trazer
não tinha montado nenhum mas eu fiquei
duas noites aquele sábado e domingo
terminando o livro chegou segunda-feira
eu entrei para quebrar e foi buscar meu
a dona da empresa quer ver meu livro
falo pra montar um livro tal e os caras
da quebrada anima muita gente
o cara falou ela vai cuspir encher o
livro [ __ ]
ela vai excluir essa mulher aí meu boi
no caso o boi pra gente não tá bom
segunda-feira leu o livro da empresa
deixei pra ela ela falou vou ler com
calma meu patrão gerentes osmar pode
ficar tranquilo a rasgar na sua cara
livre quarta feira me devolveu o livro
não tinha uma página que não tinha 134
prestados
até hoje eu devo prestar a esse papel de
maldita maneira ela colou todas as
páginas que colocou os erros do livro e
me chamou na sala novamente ele falou
sabia agora seja vai ser demitido direta
velho
eu entrei lá você viu aí os erros que eu
coloquei tal inclusive até seu nome né
de resto a cento no primeiro e r errado
uma coisa é tudo erro mesmo com e
licenciamento poético pensamento poético
méxico s
hoje
nós vamos lançar sobre roteiros mais
falei ela vai lançar um livro ele foram
acredito eu peço demissão dessa empresa
essa empresa baixa qualidade porque o
cara semianalfabeto morador da favela do
capão redondo eles vão lançar o livro do
cara tem um enfoque que tem 20 anos que
faz corrida ninguém pagou caro a mesa
não pode corrida
o livro ficou pronto
eu lancei o livro no dia 22 de novembro
de 1997
o primeiro livro a gente nunca mais
esquece né no dia do lançamento ela
fossem parabéns foi lindo nós vendemos
vários exemplares a gente fez 1500
cópias pode pegar 10 mil cópias para
você e você está demitido
admitindo que você é um péssimo
funcionário mas vai-se escritor
agora vamos chegar na minha mãe pode
falar isso mas enfim eu estou agora
vamos trabalhar aqui é quebrada ninguém
lê mas vai rolar alguma coisa na hora eu
fiquei vendo inserido nas ruas
anos e anos andando por santo amaro
avenida paulista e você pode acreditar
ninguém compra literatura de poesia em
um bairro não adianta
não adianta e fiquei vendo vários tempo
tal pegar busão passava por baixo e eu
caminho baixo da catraca pegava as malas
do livro e nada
um dia chegou a ligação da minha casa ó
a gente quer 800 exemplares de entregar
no brás
peguei um carro emprestado a um amigo
meu ele papo e deixando braz 40
execuções livros 800 exemplares
fiquei esperando o dono da distribuidora
daqui a pouco chegou seria hakimullah
foi bom o turco foi também o semanário
prazer 810 aqui poesia que fui eu só vem
de autoajuda e esoterismo aqui meu amigo
pedindo pra você errado ao ambiente de
um trote não brinca não vou falar pra
vocês eu sair de casa sem tomar café da
manhã e vendeu 800 ele traz câmera
picanha velho
o de voltar de táxi não tinha outra
metrô táxis são tivesse um táxi black
votavam nele mas nada fiquei o dia todo
na porta da distribuidora pensando numa
forma de voltar inclusive para casa
quando você está desempregado é poeta e
mora nos morros favelas do brasil você
pode ver se não tem muito amigo velho eu
não tinha para quem ligar os ligava a
cobrar os caras não atendia
não tinha como voltar com os livros foi
quebrado deu sete horas da noite
a distribuidora começou a fechar as
portas eu estava com fome naquele dia
inteiro fazendo acredito mas como eu vou
fazer com esses livros aqui daqui a
pouco passou um cara com uma carrocinha
olhou
após pegar tenta a sorte viaja sempre
pega pega 11 só para dentro do paço
pessoas já foi mais bondoso aí saiu do
carro assim quando ganhou sete e meia da
noite que o brasil cresceu soltaram
todos os caras que objetiva drogas
eu olhei pro céu falei se o me manda o
sinal por favor só o sinal ser escritor
é difícil todo mundo já me condenou cair
um pingo de chuva na minha terra começou
a garoar eu comecei a colher as caixas
do livro para dentro do normatize em
frente abrir um baile de forró
até hoje eu posso falar disso abriu o
baú do rock
o cara falou esse livro é meu amigo que
está fazendo eu falei então eu tô aqui
no servidor e tal conta a história de
próton é um pouco aqui um espaço para o
banheiro e só fazem xixi dinho eo livro
aí você vem buscando eu passei três
meses depois e no brás e buscando os 800
livros determinação
depois disso eu já passei em 44 países
já vendi mais de 200 mil exemplares só
no brasil
determinação enquanto você alcançar sem
roubar sem passar por cima de ninguém
sem mais utilizar sem assassinar e sem
perder seus valores
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]